ça c'est mon vélo de compétition donc il
est plus sorti depuis le 16 mars date du
début du confinement est il apte tout
comme moi de retrouver les copains au
bord des routes autour d'orléans
pour pallier ce manque
christophe gaillard enfile sa tenue de
cycliste chaque jour mais pour
enfourcher un nouveau compagnon de route
ce home trainer un vélo d'appartement
connectés a été achetée début mars et a
déjà beaucoup servi
alors moi depuis le 16 mars j'ai jamais
trouvé mon salon hausse est grand
puisque j'ai fait plus de 2000
kilomètres depuis le 16 mars donc je
m'en sers tous les jours tous les jours
à raison de deux à trois heures par jour
pour justement continuer à pédaler
pédaler pour entretenir la musculature
abîmée de cette jambe gauche broyés dans
un accident en 1997 cette nécessité l'a
emmené vers le cyclisme et le haut
niveau puisqu'il est le champion de
france sur route de sa catégorie
handisport et s'ils participent à ces 24
heures du home trainer dont les
bénéfices iront à une association à but
humanitaire
c'est en toute logique nous notre club
le team progresse à chartres a été créé
en 2014 avec une volonté de faire les
choses différemment
donc aujourd'hui on a la fierté de via
toutes les activités toutes les courses
que nous organisons ou auxquelles nous
participons d'avoir systématiquement une
action de mécénat solidaire pour une
association d'enfants situation de
handicap qu'on défend chaque année le
club a d'ailleurs versé 2500 euros la
semaine dernière lors d'une épreuve en
confinement et attend avec grande
impatience les prochaines sorties sur
deux roues